Time Square est tellement fou Je ne connais
personne qui habite ici Votre humble serviteur J'ai pris
le bus de Jersey Je pensais que c'était
l'endroit cool où vivre c'est la mère
Angleterre Times Square
Je n'aime vraiment pas quitter la ville où
tu vas  veux prendre le clapier
au Merritt un peu Dylan est toujours amoureux
de moi épouser mamie-claire c'est comme
acheter un pull en cachemire de Old Navy
même s'il ne l'est pas c'est un excellent
investissement qui n'oublie pas qu'elle
te doit encore ouais c'est  gagnant-gagnant parce que je suis
sûr qu'il m'aime toujours Je ne te conduis
pas dans le Connecticut pour rompre un
mariage Je devrais être dans ma chambre en train de lire l'
éthique à Nicomaque Oh calme-toi riche garçon
Je ne suis pas riche oui tu l'es tu as un  voiture
non je ne suis pas mon père est un mécanicien lui et
mon oncle ont un atelier de carrosserie j'avais cette voiture
parce que c'était quelque chose qu'il pouvait
me donner désolé je pense que j'ai offensé ton
petit ami ce n'est pas son petit ami il est à
moi pourquoi es-tu ici parce que Tracy  fait que
Tony t'a conduit mais pourquoi n'es-tu pas venu j'ai
eu une mauvaise expérience avec l'annonce  ultère
avant que mon dernier petit ami ne commette l'
adultère quand nous étions ensemble et je
n'aime tout simplement pas laisser mes petits amis
t'amener loin l'adultère pourquoi [ __ ] est-ce
important que vous ayez tous 18 ans d'où vient cette
moralité de personne âgée il n'y a pas de
tricherie quand vous  vous avez 18 ans vous devriez tous
vous toucher tout le temps
mamie-claire est mon ennemie vous avez
des affaires inachevées avec cette
femme  fiancée et a volé son idée Je n'ai jamais
regardé en arrière
ouais je vois ça mais oh je vois des
arbres
tu as dit qu'elle vit dans le Connecticut il
y a des arbres dans le Connecticut pour être juste
il y a des arbres à peu près partout
tu dois écouter l'esprit peut-être que je  peut
vous donner l'argent
hi-ho Greenwich vraiment pouvons-nous obtenir une
confirmation est l'esprit sûr de cela ouais
regardez au-delà d'un a raison elle a ce
jeune 10 10 à 12 ans de moins nous sommes
contemporains d'accord vous devez chercher
ça  mamie-claire tellement ennuyée par l'esprit
le chemin n'est pas contre toi c'est juste le
bon chemin je ne veux pas être mesquin je n'ai
tout simplement pas été élevé de cette façon elle est mon
ennemie mais elle fait
le  toi et parfois tu dois
revenir en arrière pour aller devant
ce défilé je vais à Greenwich nous
allons te préparer pour la giclée ça
va devenir moche je suis prêt super comment
on y va
je suis impressionné Brooke  il faut beaucoup de
moxie pour démarrer un restaurant merci
tu le fais bébé
tu es là-bas en train de faire quelque chose en plus d'
amasser et de thésauriser de l'argent si je pouvais
comprendre comment amasser et thésauriser de l'argent
je le ferais bien tu aurais pu te marier  moi
ou une douzaine d'autres gars mais tu veux que ce
soit ta propre personne ouais non j'en ai fini avec ça
maintenant tu es drôle parce que tu ne sais pas que
tu es drôle je sais que je suis drôle il n'y a
rien que je ne sais pas  à propos de moi c'est
pourquoi je ne peux pas faire de thérapie